Welcome to this video and this will be our first exercise.
We are going to go in and we're going to set up a behavior tree from scratch.
So jumping into the engine, hopefully you have this project downloaded.
So to kick off, the only things that I might have done differently here
is I have added in the content browser.
So you may not have started off with the content browser here.
If not, you can always click on the content browser
and I'm going to do doc in layout. It's just a preference
and it's useful for you to be able to see what I'm doing.
So I'm going to be doing a fair amount in the content browser.
Now for the behavior tree, we need to make sure we're on the behavior tree level here
and you should see something that looks a little bit like this.
And if we hit play, you're going to see that we have a quinn here
and we're able to run around and we've got a whole load of different AI
which are standing still, not doing anything at all.
So that is our starting point.
OK, so now with all of these, if you ever get stuck,
you can see I have a folder here called finished project.
This will have everything that we've made, but in its finished state.
However, we're going to be working in the behavior tree directory.
You see we have a couple of odds and sods here.
We have our MPC character.
We have an interface, but that's just going to allow us
a method of defining how to communicate with the character.
And we have our AI controller.
And so the AI controller is what is rather than the player controller,
a player controller would be the human, the kind of soul of the character.
So we would usually use a player controller in order to get the key presses
and to be the communicating point between a player character and the keyboard mouse controller.
With this, the AI controller is the equivalent, but it is all run by the computer.
OK, so to start off with, let's create a behavior tree and a blackboard.
So in order to do this, I'm going to right-hand click
and I'm going to come up to artificial intelligence.
And under this we have behavior tree.
So I'm going to create that and I'm going to call this BT underscore NPC.
So this behavior tree and PC.
Now, I am also going to right-hand click, come up to artificial intelligence
and create a blackboard.
We mentioned this before.
This is the memory of the behavior tree.
So for this, I'm going to call it BB underscore NPC.
Now, before we go in, I'm just going to do one thing that will allow us to kick this off.
So I'm going to save all before we even jump into these.
I'm going to open up the AI controller and stick it up here.
And in order to run a behavior tree, we need to tell the pawn to use it.
So the AI controller, as we mentioned before, is like the player controller.
We want to run the behavior tree.
So I'm going to do that by going to the event, begin play,
dragging off and searching for run behavior tree.
I was going to create a node like this.
The only thing that I want to do is on the drop down, I want to select the BT underscore NPC.
So that is our running of the behavior tree.
Now, I already have this NBC set up.
It might be worth quickly looking in what the settings are.
So this is just a standard parent class character.
However, within the class defaults, I also type in AI.
You can see here we have selected the AI controller class,
AI controller and behavior tree.
Now, one of the things that you might also want to be aware of is the auto-possess AI.
Now, this is set to place in the world.
Well, that's fine if you're manually placing the AI.
However, if you find that you're using something to spawn AI and it doesn't do anything,
that's probably because you've only got when it's manually placed in the world.
You can change this to placed in world or spawned.
That will mean that the AI will automatically auto-possess it if it's either placed or spawned.
So that's worth noting.
But generally speaking, there is a couple of odds and sods that we've done in here
that we'll come into later.
But that in the character is pretty much most of the stuff you need to be done
because the functionality is already there within the character movement
and the animation blueprint and everything.
That, to set up AI, is all that needs to be done within the character.
Okay, so we've done our AI controller.
We've run our behavior tree, and we had a quick look at the behavior tree character.
So I'm going to close those two down now to a save all just in case.
Now, let's have a look at the behavior tree.
So where we have bt underscore npc, if you double click to open that up,
here, you're going to see the screen that looks like this.
Now, as before, we have our root directory,
and that is every time we're going to start off,
we're going to start from root.
We're going to add some elements to that below there.
But one of the interesting things is if you come up to the top,
you can see that we have two tabs, and on the right-hand tab, we have blackboard.
And on the right-hand tab, we have blackboard.
Now, if we jump across to it, you can see that we have...
This is already set up because you can see that we have bb underscore npc.
So it has automatically correctly selected your blackboard.
Okay, so just by creating another beginning.
Now, the blackboard, we only have self actor as the only blackboard key,
and we're going to use the concept of keys here.
But keys are very much like variables.
However, we're going to be passing values in and out of these,
and we're going to be using them as inputs and all over the behavior tree.
We will create some keys in a second.
Let's go back to our behavior tree.
Now, you can see here, we've automatically selected the blackboard asset.
You could swap this out, but that's correct for our needs.
So on the right here, we have our details panel.
This is a contextual menu, as per usual.
Down here, we have a quick look at the blackboard,
and this will show us what blackboard keys are available to us as per the blackboard.
Across the top, we have a toolbar, and the elements that we're going to use a lot,
we're going to use these to create new tasks, new decorators, and new surfaces.
And we will try that out as we go through the rest of the exercise.
Now, in the center here, we have our actual behavior tree.
And you can see, as I hover over, this area goes yellow.
I could drag off much like how I could drag off in a blueprint and drop,
and it's going to give me options of elements to create.
I can right-hand click and just create stuff from scratch.
However, we'll probably do it in different ways.
The other elements I can right-hand click, and we'll be able to add in
extra functionality to here as we get going.
OK, so let's start off by having a look at two of the most common nodes that we're going to use.
And the first one is the selector.
Now, how a selector works is, I think we have to have a sequence.
You know, you can have a sequence.
OK, so we have a selector and we have a sequence.
Now, these function in a slightly different way to each other.
So what a selector is going to do is it is going to look at all of the tasks below it.
And any task below it can provide two outputs.
It can either succeed or it can fail, once the task has basically hit its completion part.
Now, I'm talking about selectors and sequences, too.
But if something under a selector fails, it's going to go instantly back.
So let me start off with a sequence. Maybe a sequence makes more sense.
So in a sequence, say I'm going to create a couple of different tasks here.
So, see, we were creating an AI very simply that was going to mimic a standard office job.
You might have a sequence for the day, and at the beginning, you would have the function of
get up, then you would have get dressed, and then we would have go to work,
and maybe finally we would have work.
And this could go on, but this is enough for our example.
Now, in this case, because this is a sequence, we would have to do all of these things
in order for this to be considered a success.
So, for example, you couldn't get dressed if you hadn't got up.
If you weren't successful at getting up, you could not get dressed.
If you haven't got dressed, it's not recommended for you to go to work.
And if you haven't gone to work, it's probably you would be able to work.
So you can see how these things have to go in a sequence.
And if any of these fails, the entire work sequence has failed.
If you fail to get dressed, if you fail to get up, if you fail to go to work,
then work has failed.
So that's all the sequences.
One by one, all of these have to succeed for us to send this back as a success.
If at any point any of these fail, the whole sequence has failed.
Now let's change go to work to be a selector, and we'll call it go to work again.
But the way a selector works is you may have multiple different tasks below it.
I'm going to drag off.
And so I'm going to take sequences just so I can.
So going to work, you might drive to work.
So your first thing to do is drive to work.
The second thing to do would be take the bus.
And the third thing to do is walk to work.
Now, the way a selector is different is if you go to work,
if you attempt to drive to work, if that is successful,
you're not going to move on to the next thing.
You're going to move on to the next thing in the sequence up here.
So the whole thing is going to be a success if you manage to drive to work.
However, if you fail to drive to work,
the selector is then going to try the second thing.
It isn't going to give up.
It isn't going to report it all as a failure.
It's going to attempt to take the bus.
So say the car doesn't work, then you try and take the bus to work.
And if that succeeds, then go to work has succeeded.
And we can go back to the work option.
Third one is if the bus fails, then we could walk to work.
And if you successfully walk to work, then you also get to work.
But the main thing is this is only considered a failure
if all of the options below it have faith.
And so if any one of the options below it succeeds,
you've officially gone to work,
and you can start on the next part of the sequence.
So hopefully this helps explain the progress of it is
that a sequence will have to go in order.
If any one of them fails, the entire sequence has failed.
The selector will select the furthest to the left.
If that fails, it will try the next one, and then the next one,
and it will only be marked as a fail if the entire of this section has failed.
Okay, there's one more thing that I think is worth noting.
And for that, I'm going to zoom in a bit.
I'm going to connect up this sequence here.
You can see that this has numbers next to each of them.
And that's important because, and it's important to recognize that
because within the rest of Unreal,
the location of the nodes placements usually doesn't matter.
The connection matters.
But in this case, if I was to drag and get dressed before get up,
you can see that this has now got a one on it,
and get up has got a two on it.
So the placement affects the order that things work in.
And our path is always going to go down the left most node first.
Okay, so that is just a little bit of a breakdown.
I feel like it's worth going over this before we jump into the actual project,
so you can see how these different elements work.
So sequences and selectors.
Great, so that's a good logical point to stop.
In the next video, we'll be building up the behavior tree itself.